Let's uh turn to a clip uh that features
Alan Ruck the actor he has been around
for a long time uh you know we loved him
in Ferris Bueller we saw him most
recently in succession and he has
something to say about the studio the
suits the heads technology capitalism uh
let's run this clip
to be kings and queens and Emperors and
now it's captains of industry and they
think that the world and everything on
it and in it everything in the air and
in the ocean belongs to them and they
think that human beings were not of
their you know socio-economic class are
just another natural resource
mostly to be managed to be utilized may
be exploited but mostly to be managed
because they always say stuff like those
people they're asking for too much well
we're not we're not asking for too much
we're asking for what's fair this isn't
this isn't about the movie stars this is
about the journeyman actors the
journeyman writers the people that that
make the thing go the wet dream for uh
some big shots is like just hire one
star and have the AI do everything else
you know well we're not gonna allow that
I mean we're not gonna allow it I mean
yeah I mean if if it could happen it'll
happen right if it can happen that's
exactly what will happen but the
solution to I mean you this will not
surprise you Nick that I think the
solution to this is more capitalism
right that the problem we have and I
actually feel like things go in Cycles
right so you had a deregulation cycle
that kind of encouraged these Behemoth
Studios and networks to join and you
know we have a you know uh Comcast is a
giant cable network and a studio and a
TV network and a streaming service
of the Pentagon as well at this point it
it I hope not because it is an
incompetent conglomerate and should not
exist definitely is a science problem
okay right right I mean it should not
exist and it will be busted up and
capitalism is what's going to bust these
things up and when they're bust and I
don't think I mean in the old days it
was that the federal Regulators you know
Richard Nixon said I don't like these TV
networks they hate me so I'm going to
make sure they can't own the TV shows
they put on because if they could do
that then they are really really rich
um now what have you had he just let
them do it they would have gotten really
really rich for like a day and then
really really poor for like a year which
is what's about to happen to all these
big companies which is why they're even
now today talking about what pieces of
their of their business they're gonna
sell right um and when they sell them
all uh everything in Show Business will
be better for the next 15 years until
they put them all back together again as
they do would you could you describe
briefly and we have a clip of uh that
we'll show after this but Rob what is
the experience of anti-capitalism in
Hollywood uh because on the one hand you
know rhetorically a lot of movie stars a
lot of writers a lot of producers a lot
of Studio heads are anti-capitalists
even as they are phenomenally successful
business people and you know good at
marketing and self-branding and all of
that stuff but what it what is it like
as being somebody who is you know on the
right politically I think you call
yourself a conservative or a maybe a
conservatorian Libertarian conservative
whatever but like you in White Castle
yeah you you like like markets you like
Freedom you like be people being able to
kind of innovate and things like that
what's what's the you know the felt
experience of anti-capitalism for you in
Hollywood
well I mean
I don't know it's the it's the uh it's
kind of the same reason that people
don't like capitalism in general it's
they don't like the uncertainty of it
that the question you have to ask
yourself with capitalism would I rather
go for the uncertainty here
change disruption all sorts of things
you know rational economic acting
or would I rather cling to something
that I know and is
um
safe and if you're at the very top of
any organization you you prefer to cling
to something that's safe capitalism the
way you and I understand it I think is
dangerous right we really had capitalism
we wouldn't have uh Goldman Sachs or we
wouldn't have JP Morgan Chase we
wouldn't have these giant regulatory
capture scenarios across the board
um so if you're a movie star and you
kind of think well I mean I know you
have giant ego and you think you're a
genius but there's always a voice inside
your head that says wait a minute
I know that I'm lucky because I almost
didn't go to that audition or I didn't
really want to be in that project that
made me the biggest whatever it is right
so you're not really crazy about
rational
economic chaos
creative destruction he liked the idea
of there being some kind of somebody
some some people in charge and you can
hear that in the in the arguments made
by you know Brian Cranston and Alan Rock
the idea that there are these malevolent
Evil Geniuses who have a plan they're
twirling their mustache up there with
the league of super villains and if we
let them let them have their plan
they're going to succeed right but the
truth is that they and that may have
been true in 2007 I think but those same
actors that by the way they are pretty
much many cases the same actors
um I mean in the corporate actors
um have utterly failed
let's look at one of those uh actors who
has utterly failed and this is Robert
Eiger Mr Iger
um I love the false decorum by the way
when people on strike are like Mr Iger
you know Etc but uh let's run the clip
of Robert Eiger because we've been
talking about this from you know kind of
okay the actors and writers are kind of
you know or I'll say I find them a
little bit annoying uh but you know the
studio heads are equally obnoxious and
by the way Bob Iger is who that is who
Cranston and uh both pretty much talking
directly specifically talking about yes
so let's here's Robert Eiger uh
beleaguered chairman of Disney we're in
the midst of a writer strike and very
likely it would seem to have a actor's
strike how is that going to impact
things and what are your expectations
there
well I think it's very disturbing to me
I you know we've talked about disruptive
forces on this business and all the
challenges that we're facing and the
recovery from covet which is ongoing
it's not completely back this is the
worst time in the world to add to that
disruption there's a level of
expectation that they have that is just
not realistic and they are adding to a
set of challenges that this business is
already facing that is quite frankly
very disruptive they're not being
realisticated I know they're not I
respect their right and their desire to
get as much as they possibly can in
compensation for their people like and I
completely respect that I've been around
long enough to understand that Dynamic
and to appreciate it but you also have
to be realistic about it with a business
environment and what this business can
deliver it is and has been a great
business for all of these people and it
will continue to be even through
disruptive times
I I wish they had pulled back so we
could see that he is standing on the
little children uh you know a mountain
of skulls yeah but how um so you know
Iger uh and Zach you had the number
we'll we'll show it in a bit but how
much did Disney lose uh in 2022 it was
uh 100 million uh 401 million dollars
um so he uh you know and he came back to
Disney so he's you know he's kind of on
the hot seat but Rob what do you what do
you how do you respond to something like
that
well look you know the irony here is
that he is the smartest guy in Show
Business really I mean he's a very smart
guy
um and his uh company is just too Giant
and he started Disney plus and he
shouldn't have
um
he did a lot of dumb things and he's
right that if you believe that
if you've done this terrible job running
these big media companies
and you're looking at your you know
quarterly earnings or your annual
earnings you're looking at the future in
the future competition and how much it's
going to cost you to keep feeding your
machine for content for 11 a month and
you don't have any pricing power they
don't have any pricing power these
people
um
they're in a business they've never been
in before
consumer product business that's what a
superior service is they don't make
consumer products they make TV shows
right they're not making Fritos they're
making TV shows
um they have no there's no experience in
this business and the business is
kicking their ass
um but if you insist that that's the
business you're in yes of course it's
incredibly meddlesome and Troublesome
and disruptive and unrealistic for the
writers and the actors to ask you to do
something else because you're like Hey
listen it's like you know we've driven
the car into a ditch stop you know I
don't have time to like get you a
cheeseburger or whatever it is right but
the driving it into the ditch was the
problem the problem isn't now that you
know you guys aren't on our side they
haven't offered any you know notice
these they never offer you like shares
in the company you know they don't do
that they're not they're not really
offering to make you a stakeholder in
the business so
you know he's smart but I I I there is
no solution for these people even if
even if somehow they it turns out that
the studios strike a deal that they
believe they can then sell to the
shareholders is like a good deal there
is no future for these companies except
to be to break themselves up and they
will it sounds you know while you were
talking it reminds me a bit of the uh
airline industry which goes through
these cycles of booms and busts and
where right smaller Airlines buy each
other and they become bigger because
they're going to have economies of scale
and market share and then they can
dictate you know their pricing power and
it never quite works out that way and
then occasionally you'll get like years
ago United the employees are like okay
well you know we're going to buy it
because that way we'll own the company
we're a part of and the pendant they did
that they were like we don't know how to
run an airline we don't want to and they
tried to sell it back Etc so maybe we're
going through one of these Cycles Zach
let's talk um you have some slides about
just like looking at the big picture of
uh you know what you know how's it how's
it working out for Studios that kind of
support a lot of what Rob is talking
about here yeah so we mentioned Disney
posting a negative 401 million dollar uh
loss in 2022 Netflix uh you'll see here
you know Netflix Sony both uh
uh down uh profit-wise Warner Brothers
NBC Universal Paramount posted modest in
cream there profit margins for 2022 uh
the writer's Guild provided this
historical graphic uh which you see you
know billions uh tens of billions in
operating profits for the the big
companies over the years although they
also concede that 2022 in particular was
a rough year uh for the industry
um this just shows the executive pay for
all the big Studio Chiefs
um and you know in in the hundreds tens
to hundreds of millions first some of
them uh most many of them uh did take a
pay cut in 2022 although you know still
living
Aria Emmanuel only at about 20 million
uh yeah well you know I already built a
business
Rob can we go back to that real quick
yeah can you know Rob one of the things
that you hear again and again uh you
know from you know say the Allen rux of
the world is that it is obscene Aria
Manuel who is part of the leading you
know he's the brother of Rahm Emanuel
he's a liberal Democrat if not a
progressive Democrat he has made uh you
know in the past five years he's made
346 million dollars and Alan Ruck says
that is obscene that is wrong he doesn't
deserve to make that much money is Alan
Ruck is Alan Ruck right no he's wrong
area Emanuel built a business business
he built it he's not like it's a
everybody who pay it's a by the way it's
a business built on fees right you know
the business itself was a talent agency
he's got a lot of other pieces of pieces
to it now but it started as a talent
agency people willingly and get engaged
in a contract with Arie Emanuel because
he was a passionate and great talent man
challenge agent representative and they
gave him a portion of their earnings and
he worked for them he built that
business Patrick weitzel's on the bottom
of that Patrick's another partner at WME
and he he did that it's like no of
course he deserves it that that's not I
mean and lumping him in with some of the
sort of factotums there is it doesn't
seem fair uh I would say and I say that
somebody who's not represented by Airy
at all but but I he built a business he
deserves it he earned that money I'm not
I don't I don't I I it's it the when it
when the argument becomes about uh
people getting rich and they shouldn't
be getting rich you know that the
they've lost the threat of the argument
the argument really should be
um you're not going to pull this
business out of a ditch by giving me a
pay cut and by removing uh income
streams from me you're gonna still have
to live up to the standards of paying me
for resid my either my residuals in my
image or my residuals in my writing and
you have to figure out another way to
pull your company out of the ditch and
the way to do that is I keep saying over
and over again is just simply make it
smaller like you find somebody to buy
this if every single one of those
companies you had up there
broke itself into pieces of exhibiting
and
Studio
um like a content creator and then a
contract content exploiter
it would be like the golden years again
and everyone and the idea the fear there
is that okay well nobody will sell me no
no studio will sell me their content
right that was the net big Netflix fear
which is just completely ludicrous that
just there's just no evidence for that
at all and there's so much counter
evidence to it Netflix's own ratings or
that like and and creating a a lucrative
back end which is what we're talking
about for uh for content is something
that's in the is benefits the whole
environment everyone does better
do you think that's uh are you
optimistic that is a likely outcome here
for the future of the industry because I
mean one interesting aspect of this go
around with the actors is that sag-aftra
has already issued some waivers to some
of the smaller independent production
companies is that kind of how it starts
to break apart that there that really
these smaller maybe more Nimble players
are going to be able to move forward
while the big ones are kind of stuck in
the mud I think it breaks apart because
the shareholders
um eventually wake up
I mean the entertainment business is a
very great very very good place to go
and for individuals to get extremely
rich
it is not a good place for shareholders
to get rich shareholders need to learn
that lesson about every 15 20 years but
they do learn it and there'll be some
activist shareholders some whoever the
latest is that's in some giant
hedge fund who's going to like oh yeah
you're speaking of uh Catholic nuns
right yeah probably right the same ones
who go to Exxon Mobil meetings show up
right now it'll be some of his fun guys
who's going to make trouble for Sherry
Redstone or make trouble for somebody
and say why do you own this stuff you're
failing at it you're failing at your
streaming service you're failing at your
studio sell it is there any is there any
indication that somebody like Reed
Hastings at Netflix is kind of getting
that message or the or the leaders at
Amazon where you know there it becomes
even more unclear you know uh I've read
that over half of American households
are are Amazon Prime households that
throws off a lot of money Prime video is
one of the ways that you keep people
being Prime households so maybe they
don't really care how many people are
watching or you know and they have yeah
but that's a problem apple and Amazon
don't care right yeah
yeah just to show that up data on
Netflix here this is the subscriber base
for Netflix from 2013 to present uh
where you know closing in on 250 million
paid subscribers worldwide so yeah you
do have to think like even if uh things
they're struggling right now that's
that's a lot of people uh there's got to
be a way to figure out how to turn that
around right well but but not not if
you're spending money the way they spend
money on content but
for this Slide the terror on that slide
is the first quarter of 2020 of 2022.
because that is the first quarter that
the subscriber growth I think it was
definitely first quarter so maybe I'm
looking at the yeah now you're right
that's the first quarter that subscriber
growth
didn't flatten it didn't slow it went
down yeah and the rule was that this
that will never happen it'll just slow
and Plateau they called it and then they
discovered that the people who had
people who gave up Netflix right they
weren't the people you expected people
who got it
in December of 2021 because they wanted
to watch movies over the holidays or
they got it because they were you know
in 2020 they were they were it was
during the pandemic they were all home
the people who gave up their Netflix
membership in the first quarter of 2022
were people who've been subscribers to
Netflix for two plus years which was not
supposed to be possible
that the whole model was built on the
fact that once you do it you're not
going to check your credit card bill
anymore you're not even going to know
what that is who's that what the hell is
whatever it is but they didn't that
didn't happen which of course anybody
anybody at like Procter and Gamble or
the Frito-Lay Corporation would have
said you know that's not going to work
right that's not how consumers buy
um but these guys have no map no no
experience in that so they had no idea
um so but my long my short answer to
your question Nick is that no I I they
should I mean if you look at all of the
Netflix you know literature and the
stories around Netflix always they're
hyper rational kind of nice yeah they
have like data analytics and for in
through employees too like you know Hey
listen you were employee number three
but you no longer fit into the system so
you're like you self-fire yourself you
think this is a kind of a cult right a
cult of rational actors right and yet
the minute they touch show business
that was an excerpt of our reason
livestream with Rob long talking about
the writer's Guild strike and the
sag-aftra strikes if you want to watch
another excerpt go here and if you want
to watch the whole thing go here and
make sure to come back next Thursday at
1 pm eastern time when reasons live
stream we'll be talking with somebody
who's very interesting saying stuff that
you definitely want to hear